let's get everybody welcome back to
first act here we have top four of the
action it's gonna be a good one so far
hopefully you've enjoyed it's a gem and
Romanova on the mic hopefully you guys
have been having a great night we're
getting late here we're tuning in to the
nitty gritty it's it's usually around
the tar the time that wins a knife fight
starts on my time so I'm feeling nice
and pumped you know this is usually when
we get into things and it's fair enough
that we see some west coast East Coast
action going on on the stage it's gonna
be a good one so far winner of this
match in case you guys are wondering you
haven't seen the brag we'll be playing
up against the Nunes they're super noon
in our losers finals winner of that will
be playing up against Chris G so this is
gonna be a good one
Nakia versus apology man I like the
energy here like we were saying these
two they're really funny to watch
Interactive oh yeah
I just imagine with naki out playing Kid
Buu that like he does like the Kid Buu
level 3 when apology man really makes
him angry is definitely docu if you guys
don't know he is a screamer for sure
I've never met anybody who screams more
things in my life like the way he yells
the way he yells but like he just takes
it out on the sky for awake anything
anything gonna happen in the world and
he would just turn and be like goodies
of what have you done I got my own oh
this is bad so it's gonna be our loser
sending us enemies here and again I'm
excited to watch this and see how it
what you doing bro yeah we gonna do you
think the devices we actually he's ready
he's ready he's right back into it
Manson let me desync the devices now
hold us down right off the bat yeah well
this is committed for a mix-up is not a
bad idea as long as it pays off but it
opened up the field for a volume and do
the same
aggressive here both super-dense the
same time gets clipped by the DP don't
go hannes this but it doesn't matter
both / - is happening at the same time
sounded like a jet engine taking off
side switch uses the Gowanus is this a
pretty scary spot to be stagger pressure
in the corner of the 2h that is a skill
that people have really developed a lot
and it's not easy to do you have to do
your chain and then do the 2h in there 2
feet the car cancel really Tom and top
players are talking very very good at it
as we see the gumball setup a lot of our
top players they are just waiting and
ready to punish those are counsels yeah
it's not easy to do H mystic ball
overhead again apology man on defense
but finally gets back with its parking I
mean ok it worked out but he doesn't get
piccolo in for this snappy it already
uses their action so no double jump yeah
he recovered off the head is just so
unfortunate getting mystic ball they're
going into the level 1 levelling up go
on yeah and you got Kid Buu out which is
huge right you want to keep kids alive
so you can do stuff like you know go on
to H legs and a gumball assist into
setting up a mixup which we're gonna see
here but he caught him low anyway jump
medium but he didn't yeah
I'll do it well blame knock you know
it's important to get this team kind of
discombobulated especially to get rid of
that assist right I mean piccolo had to
spend sparking early didn't get anything
with it because of the combo drops Lane
call-out with the 2h that was a rough
spot to be right outside the corner east
he's dead that's one of those situations
where like the air - the mix-up is hard
to deal with because you're in the
corner and you don't know if he's you
know has enough room to go for the cross
or not yeah stagger pressure trying to
wait for the assist to come back and
that put it of a bead that's pressure
you game - once you're leveled up with
going on off the auto combo unfortunate
as that should be this is sliding
knockdown though but manages to get a
hit in anyways and you make quick work
of team go on yeah big drop but it ended
up working out therefore knock yes he's
sitting on two characters and sparking
which is like humongous leap as far as
the smash is concerned I feel like it's
always a good time for not yet when he
still has adult Gohan as one of his
characters left yeah
yeah I mean you know sometimes you're
sad about not having a kid Lance but
that's one of those moments for having a
penis is really nice it's going through
the or but the to wait for the kill nice
work yeah
Game one gonna nappy oh yeah I think
there was a couple of drops there on
both sides that are a little weird but
the game plan for Nike all worked out
quite well I think
and I think of your apology man you
really have to look at the moments where
you dropped those big piccolo combos and
think like okay well that could have
been the star of like maybe a different
game you know oh the switch to tian
beerus get out of here no it's not gonna
happen it was just having worst unit
representing the BBC he's trying to hang
out to find him I mean that might may be
beerus is actually answer to GT goku cat
versus a rat could you imagine if that
was the secret all along we're just so
foolish that we thought beerus is only
good for clawed 805 s like sparking
combos on twitter it turns out he's
actually good how could we have not seen
them but still believe it on we have
skeezer excuse it's true there's people
that still believe in beerus i feel like
if you play a good shell around them
it's not the end of the world but we're
not gonna see that here yeah no reason
to make life harder
well Japan just need to take a little
bit of a breather there and we are going
back into our game to hear let's see if
you're gonna make this comeback double
backlash start yeah knock you'll hit
that standing hell on the ground but
with sandwich between the beans and a
namekian which is a bad spot to be
I would like to see in this game - is
trying to make sure that you can prevent
go on from leveling up as much as
possible I think that once y'all gets
that momentum you just keep going and
going yeah it's just tough right I mean
that's one of those characters that you
know any of his characters can enable a
level up oh wow the super - Pete the tag
oh the other weird ball mystic ball
again not a real crazy mix-up hey this
one for the L which is like a bid yeah
and if you think it's going to go for
that like to Emma Graham and Kid Buu
then doing the super - is a really good
call off one damage we'll see what the
sparking situations like Wow beautiful
call out waited for ya cross up elbow
oldest trick in the book
ya know Kelly didn't have any meter
mystic balls himself into death there
yeah I'm kind of surprised but that
super - didn't get eaten up by it to be
honest with you but it worked out all
right level up not easy to punish but he
was ready I think I saw the beam go out
to thing and it's gonna protect them
when I try to level up and it just
didn't work that way yeah it's a very
common ground star for Knockhill he does
level up into GC Goku says that is
really bad yeah
barking instead of level 3 is a huge
loss I think Nakia try to uppercut maybe
I'll start there and it didn't come out
super - comes out try and get some hits
on him go for the low man it's so crazy
that he's blocking low every single time
yeah reflect out of them barkings run
out to get the heavier Ottapalam inside
yeah he has an assistive ailable so he
can slice into the assist zone
she's gonna set up the floor here knock
yell hey get that dragon rushed oh yeah
to em run up dragon rush he's got a lot
of meter but he needs a lot of hits this
is definitely a really really far match
from winning yes to burn through a
sparking he's got to burn through three
characters we have a lot of life oh the
change Enzo is gonna get the hit and
that is where that sparking is gonna hit
four bars on deck four apology man five
yeah it's been the level three Harry
there's a lot of damage
yeah extending it as much as possible
still not enough
Wow wake up light light
yeah powered up level 3 up level 3
I mean sometimes you got to do you got
one character left waking up light light
light I don't why not alright just give
it a shot not enough oh let's see P I
mean you don't have a lot to lose yeah
yeah you don't have a lot to lose you
might as well try right like luck all
right well if that character dies I got
two characters with lots of life left
not a big deal final game between these
two one apiece
right now yeah I mean we've seen that a
lot of this top here right a bunch of
West Coast players in the winter side
drop drop each other down oh that was
messed up spark out the GPSS hits but
nothing often inoculant gasps very loud
really hard to get a consistent clean
pump off of that yeah weird scrambles
lots of like straight hits that it
didn't print anything slicer cutting for
ya i canna carry to the corner here
elbow dragon runs right into the level
three here oh yeah instead of whiff and
then the wake up reflect I think he was
expecting an air dash or something like
that securing that hit there got three
bars on deck still got two characters
left get a level up go on yeah that jump
BAM very common option after price nine
people thank you for taking up oh I like
that heavy legs and it dodged and
minutes just to dodge that beam and he
gets the hit off those jump lights yeah
this is awesome he's gonna get the drop
here he's got a little three available
just goes for the air - OH
I like the movement that we're seeing
here from very big if you just waited a
little bit before you super - you got a
2h said
snap that will jump out we've been
seeing that all top a from Knockhill
[Music]
reversal level three I like that idea a
lot yeah
there was no assists so he you know he
knew he was gonna have to stack or some
way if you wanted something I like that
idea from Paulo a lot of blue life on
the table for not feel here in that
situation they're not now sitting on six
bars all that blue help do that cheeky
Goku has VPS - that was a lot of hits
their abilities punished with the
special beam cannon and then there's a
lot of blue life here I think it's gonna
take a look at the level three in bonus
that's a huge snipe kill piccolo with
this I think he you know not get than
that for this arena just looking for
anything to dump that meter on to get
him out of there
really good time and if you're yeah
we're just gonna say you need to snap
backs off it's exactly what a college
and I needed the snap so he wanted the
dragon rush for any hit early so that he
can get it he'll be either of their
games I mean definitely the help lead
mirror for apology man but come back hey
that was a really far range pickup super
- that was so far away I thought she
wasn't gonna be able to cover that much
do
and kill I cannot believe that super
daft work that was insane we do have a
level up Gohan right now yeah so I use a
level up I think in this game the thing
is about them is that has been meter is
the problem to get pressure so low it's
like he's gonna need H legs and then
he's not gonna build anymore bar apology
man so far has looked really great in
this last game particular missed the
side switch combo super patient all the
air - over nice work - apology man as he
moves on to losers finals for that run
back Avenger he's gonna make a lot of
Porto Rican dollars this weekend yeah
make sure make sure he converts all the
currency I cannot believe that super -
flew across the entire screen and then
hit that was messed up I was I've never
seen it go that far it was like he flew
literally the entire screen in connected
I was like oh